hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and welcome back to my channel you know
uh last few days I've been doing some
videos on imbalances and their effect on
the market and you know order flow in my
opinion is something that's very visual
for a Trader you know we we can see
things in the order flow and make a
quick decision and
um thin Prince is actually sometimes
it's the result of an imbalance taking
place in the market now
um we know the market trades in a
two-way auction right there's a bid and
there's an offer okay so for example say
the market is uh you know 80 79 and
three quarters bid offered at 80. you
know when it traded when it was trading
in this two-way auction there was
actually nothing traded on the offer at
80 it left to zero that's what I call a
thin print
um here it's 52 against one when the
market was 78 78 and a quarter only one
lot traded on the offer at 78 and a
quarter and even at 80 when it was off
at 78 rather
um 64 traded on the bid at 77 three
quarters only one contract traded at 78.
and again you know lots of times it is
the result of something that's left over
in an imbalance and you know because an
imbalance is basically
you know more volume trading either on
the bidder than the offer okay so you
know by ratio like four to one so
obviously when you get zero you know and
you trade at least uh you know five
contracts you're gonna get
um you're gonna be left with an
imbalance right and really the the
important part of understanding thin
prints is really it's a market that's
you know it's another sign of a market
that's moving fast and as a Trader you
know you want to be alerted to these
areas on the chart where there's lack of
volume right I was talking about that
last week it's not always about reading
the order flow looking for big trades
going through
you also want to see these areas where
there's a lack of volume trading in the
two-way auction so it's one thing to
have a big order going through and
that's important however you also gotta
be looking at how the big order is
trading in the market is there somebody
uh trading against it at the same time
or not right because at the end of the
day if all you have is a big order going
through the market
and there's no counter trade that's
going to be important okay and what I
want to show you guys is you know if
you're looking at a footprint chart this
I this is just a basic footprint chart
right
um you know I don't have any value areas
or any other tools up on here other than
um you know basically your bid ask
footprint as well as you know the point
of control and imbalances that's it
right and thin prints was something that
I've always looked for in the market
right and I can see you know there's a
zero here what does that mean well that
means to me that there was no counter
trade right I mean well obviously it
means there's no counter trade but I
know that this is in a sense poor order
flow it's in a way a gap in the bar and
you can see how the market sold off came
all the way back up and traded right to
that level one tick passed I then
continued on down it repaired that poor
order flow now there's times where you
know you'll have a zero print or you
know a thin volume print and the market
just comes right back within a bar into
and fills it right and it's sort of
Forgotten
um but when you start identifying these
on a chart over time you start to see
that these carry significance for
Traders and you know somebody asked me
today I was doing a training earlier
today
um Mike you know what what's the the
three if you had to just pick three
tools of order flow that
you could just work with right you don't
have to use anything else what are the
three one of them is thin prints the
other one's Prominent Point of controls
other one you know it's sort of a tie
between value areas and um in Market
weakness so what we have programmed
inside of the order flows Trader is a
way to identify
these thin prints in the bar and not
only that but you know highlight them as
well as you know draw zones out from
them and identify even bars that have
more than one Thin print you know
generally
markets you know a thick markets that
trade a lot of volume e-mini is a
perfect example do a very good job of
Distributing volume throughout a bar
okay because you know generally at at
every level you're going to get you know
a couple hundreds even thousands of of
contracts going through but what about
those areas
where there's essentially very little
volume going through right and you can
see here this is what I was talking
about earlier right you get the zero
print right here inside the bar Market
sells off comes right back up
gets one tick pass and then has a nice
sell-off right here again another zero
print coming in here get one to pass and
then sell off and sometimes right
immediately in the next bar it comes
right back and sort of fills in that
poor order flow as it's what's happening
down here with the zero
um the one now
just really quick and again depending on
the market that you're trading okay this
is e-minis okay so for example let's go
I'll just show you the settings really
quick
um thin print you could set the
volume that you want to look at so for
example okay I'll just switch over to uh
10 years really quick now 10 years I
don't really Advocate using a one minute
chart it's a little uh difficult to wrap
your head around sometimes I like to use
a range based charts on on treasuries
and so this is a market that trades
generally very strong volumes right at
each level you see thousands of
contracts it's a four range chart four
thousand four thousand you know fifteen
hundred Seventeen hundred five thousand
seven thousand right you got a zero here
what happens you got one two three it's
a stack buying a bounce but look at this
this one is hasn't been retested in the
next bar we came in tested these two
and what do we do we came right back
down to it three minutes later now this
happened I believe on um Friday we had
some numbers coming out right which
caused this here it caused this bar here
because this is all it's in the nine
o'clock minute but don't know how it
came right down to that tick but
basically the point that I want to try
to make for you with um
you know these thicker markets you don't
have to use something like zero and one
especially on a market like treasuries
10 years that trade you know thousands
of contracts
per price level per tick right so you
know you can use uh where's thin prints
in here or t okay yeah you could use
something like you know 20 or 25 to
highlight those areas of
thin prints you know here's 14 here's
seven right in this case we came we sold
off we went back out within a tick of it
and came off a little bit
um you know even up here having some
movements so again you could adjust it
to whatever you want and you know again
you know something like a thin print is
a sign of a market that's moving fast
because what's happening is
um you know you have a big order going
through now again like I said sometimes
it's the results of an imbalance in the
market you know and you can see the
physical imbalance 44 against 197
against zero
um
okay
Etc but at the end of the day you know
again we're so used to looking at
imbalances especially stacked imbalances
that it's a very visual thing for a lot
of Traders and sometimes you know you're
gonna get these things happening these
thin prints without an imbalance
or without a stacked imbalance right
because again if you're looking for you
know a stacked imbalance you're not
getting that stacked imbalance here
especially if you're using a range based
chart here right and you can see there's
a lot of great trading opportunities let
me just go back to the e-minis really
quick
um change that back to a simple one
minute chart
okay
and just get back to to Friday's
activities okay but again you know it's
flexible right depending on the market
that you're trading right it's going to
determine on you know what you want to
do identify as a thin print so for
example I just get back let's go back to
the cash open on Friday
right where are we here Cash open now
again maybe you don't want to look at
you know volumes of
9 10 or anything above that so you just
want to just just you want to be very
specific right you want to have just uh
areas of zero volume in the two-way
auction okay so you just change that
thin print
max volume to zero click ok
okay
now there's a couple other little tools
we have in here uh thin print multiple
thin prints right so you can identify
bars that have multiple thin Prints but
look at this where okay this was right
ahead of the cache so once cash opened
up here yeah we went up came right back
down we had this thin print got a couple
ticks through had a nice move up right
thin print thin print one two three thin
prints you'll notice all right this
Bar's got this green box around because
it's got multiple thin prints in it
right again these in this case I
set it to zero right which is the lowest
you can go obviously you can't go
negative you can't have negative volume
in a bar
here look at this couple more thin
prints in there two more two more and
there's one here right there's one there
okay as the market is selling off again
I like to have thin prints where
the market doesn't retrace back into it
right because there's two ways to trade
it right you could trade it on a
pullback right you just drop in a limit
there have a two or three tick stop
and look for the pop-up right because
basically you're looking for this order
flow to be repaired
or once you have your thin print
printing then you know you got some
momentum in this market you could look
to get short as soon as you start
trading below the bar with a thin print
and it if it's a short or above you know
to get long above the bar with a thin
print in it right because look at that I
mean you could have got long in here in
off this bar off this bar obviously this
bar here but you'd rather be getting
long earlier down around the 64-65 area
or even 67 then getting long up at 77
right because you know you want to be
positioned
catch this move here all right
you know even here after the cash open
right that was Friday let's take a look
at a different day Thursday just scroll
back here similar activity
okay where's the cash open
I used Cash open okay this is the one
minute before two minutes before cash
opens up here got your thin print in
this bar again it was coming down trying
to fill in that Gap
um and then it shot up to new highs
right even here another thin print right
maybe you don't take this one because
cash just opened if you take this one
right look at this bar
there's no other reason in this bar to
be getting long other than that thin
print this Bar's got your stack behind
and not stacked buying imbalances but
it's got one two three four five six
seven binding balances
but would you have gotten long off this
bar well you would have if you
understood the whole concept of thin
prints
okay Market went up hey
chart
okay thin print bearish one here it was
a bearish one here it came in tested it
in the next bar six contracts traded
then it sold off
um you know a couple thin prints in here
but we're already selling off again if
we have a sell-off from you know people
say well you got thin prints down here
Market didn't go anywhere well yeah I
mean we just sold off from you know 38
down to 18 yeah 20 points sell-off do
you really want to get short and there's
other reasons in this bar why you don't
want to get short anyway
um off that but you can see how look at
these levels right came down there's a
thin print from way before trade through
it by six ticks this one came down
within one tick just missed it just
nicked it
um forming your low here now you get
your bullish thin prints here get a nice
move up all right so you know being able
to identify the thin prints in a chart
again depending on the market you're
using this is a e-mini
um one minute chart
if you're using you know if you're
trading you know a different Market
again this is set to zero you know if
you're looking at say
you know I showed you the 10 years I
don't know crude oils take a look at
crude CL
again just keeping it at zero
okay again a night session you're gonna
get a lot of zeros but uh during the day
session all right you can see you get me
some nice
um
nice movements on the way up
right you don't have necessarily stacked
imbalances coming in on this bar or this
bar or this bar but it's giving you some
nice bullish signals here
okay so again you know if there's
there's certain things that people
always ask me you know one of the
questions I get a lot is what was what's
the one thing if you put on your chart
that you'd use on order flow well I
would use thin prints now again if
you're trading a very ill liquid Market
I don't know uh Hogs he on a one minute
chart okay you can get a lot of zeros
right so it's not going to be effective
I wouldn't recommend trading a one
minute chart with thin prints on on Hogs
I'd probably try to uh aggregate the
trades a bit more I don't know maybe use
something like a 50 tick chart or
something like that it's going to give
me a little bit better uh price
movements Etc
um you know or even if I was going to
use something I don't know
a four Range Five range chart maybe
um so anyway there's different ways to
play around with it but again you know
having that on your software is a great
tool that you can use
um
you know to identify these areas of lack
of volume going through in the market so
thanks everyone I'll see you guys on the
next video bye-bye